au plus fort de la crise sanitaire la
plupart des professions pour ne pas dire
toutes ont été impactés il en est une
quand même qu'il aura peut-être été plus
durement ou du moins plus longuement et
c'est la restauration représentant
emblématique du secteur dans la région
le restaurant la côte d'or à saulieu
fait aujourd'hui ses retrouvailles avec
la clientèle
c'est le moment de dresser le bilan de
cette traversée de crise et de voir
comment se passe cette reprise
d'activité c'est dominique loiseau qui
nous accueille
[Musique]
bonjour 2000 peugeot bonjour emmanuel
merci de nous accueillir
je vous en prie asseyez-vous alors cette
période que vous avez traversé elle
était inédite est ce qu'elle a été
particulièrement difficile
ça s'est relativement bien passée pour
l'entreprise nous étions fermés mais
grâce au gouvernement nous avons quand
même pu payer nos salariés
c'est un geste formidable qui a été fait
pour la profession pour la restauration
et puis ben ce qui me concerne j'ai
rangé mon bureau j'ai fait plein de
choses j'ai surtout jardinier la
clientèle nous a beaucoup à plédran la
fermeture les clients voulait vraiment
venir attendait dès qu'il y avait un
petit signe comme quoi il y aurait un
déconfinement on avait tout de suite des
réservations malheureusement tout dû
être annulé après et dès qu'on a ouvert
bien là on a été complet tout de suite
et pour les clients
ça a été un soulagement je devrais dire
une renaissance
vraiment
alors christophe vous avez pu tailler
toutes les roses fanées et toutes les
branches mortes parce qu'avec cette
pluie les rosiers ont beaucoup souffert
parfait et il faut bien tout nettoyer
tous les petits coins zéro point non
merci à toutes à la remercie
on vous sent très impliqué quand même le
votre jardin mon jardin c'est ma passion
parce que je n'ai pas de vrais
jardiniers ici et donc j'ai
progressivement en quelques années j'ai
beaucoup étudié plus beaucoup de livres
lit des livres spécialisés des magazines
et maintenant je suis là paysagère de la
maison ça a été aussi votre refuge
pendant ce confinement exactement bah
écoutez c'est bien simple durant tout le
confinement
je n'ai fait que jardinier ici et dans
mon jardin personnel je sais pas ce que
j'ai pu faire durant tant de mois mais
je n'ai pas arrêté de créer de nouveaux
endroits des nouvelles atmosphères avec
un bon angle chaise là enfin bon ça a
été de la grande gourmandise
entre son jardin et le spa dominique
loiseau est passé du vert au bleu
en attendant que la clientèle elle
puisse de nouveau passé rate un jour je
vous présente pascal à berne note qui
est le directeur de du relais bernard
loiseau à saulieu
voilà depuis 15 ans depuis 2006 est-ce
que vous ne vous emmèneriez voir les
cuisines par exemple plaisir mais
allons-y
dominique loiseau bercy un coup mais je
travaille à bientôt à bientôt et merci
[Musique]
les deux restaurants du relais l'oiseau
d'essence et la côte d'or sont distincts
mais dans les couloirs secrets
d'établissement leur cuisine se
rejoignent et le personnel en a retrouvé
le chemin
[Musique]
l'activité a repris oui
autant il se passait plus rien pendant
pratiquement sept mois on a eu aucune
activité sachant que
mieux étant tellement aller 47,2 des
grandes villes
on n'avait aucun doute et nous de faire
de la vente à emporter donc on a dû à
contrecoeur fermer totalement
l'établissement
comment se sont passées les
retrouvailles à la fois avec la
clientèle et le personnel en plastique
on a eu le sentiment d'avoir été
emprisonnés chez nous contre notre ville
bien sûr et donc le fait de se retrouver
déjà tous à retrouver le plaisir les
sensations de notre métier
les odeurs les bruits ensuite de
retrouver nos clients
on imagine que la clientèle était
impatiente de revenir et les revenus
elle est contente très impatient ravis
et sincèrement le personnel l'équipe
tout le monde est enchanté de ce
commencé à revivre à retrouver des
sensations
notre métier c'est à des marchands de
bonheur et on pouvait vous pouvez pas
espérer mieux que de retrouver une
clientèle aussi aussi rapidement et dans
de meilleures conditions et bien le
monde est rassuré merci bonne
continuation à vous et merci de votre
accueil / merci de votre colis au revoir
après bientôt à bientôt merci beaucoup
au revoir
voilà l'épisode est passé tout le monde
a été heureux de se retrouver heureux
aussi de voir que la machine avait été
relancée
[Musique]